liebe zuschauer ich mache es heute so
wie die allermeisten meiner
fernsehkollegen und melde mich aus
meinem privaten wohnzimmer hinter mir
das alte billy regal mit den büchern aus
meiner studentenzeit das soll euch
zuhause beweisen ja ich bin auf dem
teppich geblieben ich wohne wie ihr
ich bin einer von euch den in diesen
tagen sind wir tatsächlich alle gleich
deswegen ist es ja so weh
[Applaus]
alles von ikea
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
heute-show deutschland diskutiert über
die masken pflicht das vermummungsverbot
und ich habe gleich ich persönlich bin
tatsächlich pro maske denn für mich ist
es optisch eine klare verbesserung ja
selbst wenn so ein teil nur verhindert
dass man andere infiziert reicht das
doch als argument
erst recht bei einer krankheit die auch
ohne symptome bereits ansteckend ist
warum tragen denn die menschen in asien
schon seit jahrhunderten solche masken
warum aus gründen natürlich muss man
zusätzlich abstands und hygieneregeln
einhalten ist ja klar und das teil
korrekt aufsetzen
armin laschet zum beispiel der übt
offensichtlich noch wie diese bilder
beweisen
lustig dass keiner der anwesenden ärzte
sich getraut hat ihm das zu sagen
herr ministerpräsident ihr zinken hängt
raus naja jetzt muss man fairerweise
dazusagen der armin hat danach im
internet noch demonstriert wie man das
teil richtig trägt genau so und so schön
dass es dass sich viele menschen jetzt
ihre masken selber nähen häkeln oder
töpfern
wir haben ja nicht mal genug für das
medizinische personal hier ein total
überrascht der minister
das wir uns jemals so dinge die
eigentlich mal wenige cent gekostet
haben es ging ja um bei den masken um 6
78 cent auf dem weltmarkt zu streiten
würden und das macht sich dann auch in
den preisen bemerkbar das ist ja wie bei
den goldpreisen ein hoch und runter
gerade das denke ich hat so niemand
erwartet
nein niemand konnte das erwarten niemand
also es sei denn ein gewisses
robert-koch-institut hätte die
bundesregierung schon 2013 in einer
studie
exakt davor gewarnt nämlich vor zitat
engpässen bei schutzausrüstung und
desinfektionsmittel ja aber dafür hätte
man das dicke gutachten vom rk ihr
regelrecht lesen müssten und das lag hat
die letzten jahre unter diesem einen
tisch im gesundheitsministerium der
immer so gewackelt hatte
egal egal wir kriegen das schon
irgendwie geregelt
im krisen entstehen halt mal engpässe
dass es immer noch kein grund zur panik
zurück zum hopfen viele tausend leute
werden da im april benötigt kommen die
nicht könnte am ende auch das bier
teurer
ich bin gleich wieder da
das war knapp der letzte kasten ja ja
damit komme ich so gerade noch über
meinen samstag leider hat unsere masken
knappheit noch eine ganz schlimme
nebenwirkung und dies gar nicht lustig
die teile fehlen nämlich vor allem in
senioren- und pflegeheim und das
widerspricht so ein bisschen dem tollen
plan unsere alten als risikogruppe
besonders zu schützen
also bestimmt gelesen kooning nennt man
das cocooning klingt einfach schöner als
ein sperren so umso bitterer dass corona
jetzt die altersheime erreicht hat mit
katastrophalen aber ehrlicherweise
erwartbaren folgen gerade für das
pflegepersonal da hätte man längst
schutzkleidung besorgen müssen
das lag doch auf der hand und dann sind
da übrigens auch noch gut 300.000
haushalte in denen pflegekräfte aus
osteuropa arbeiten wer schützt die oder
oder sorgt dafür dass die hier wieder
einreisen dürfen sie hat gerade zu mir
gesagt sie würde niemals deutschland
verlassen und die ältere
pflegebedürftige person alleine lassen
nicht die frau streicheln wir haben
corona ja leider ist das motto gerade
meine oma fährt im hühnerstall motorrad
denn da ist es sicherer als im altenheim
übrigens 21 prozent der deutschen sind
65 oder älter 21 prozent
da hätten wir ordentlich was zum
weggucken wenn die rentner das über wohl
oder wir setzen doch mehr auf handy
tracking über die daten unserer telefone
infektionswege nachverfolgen hat jens
spahn früher vorgeschlagen
ja zugegeben das klingt erstmal wie der
feuchte traum der stasi ist aber
vielleicht gar nicht so blöd eine corona
waren app würde alarm schlagen wenn ich
mich in der nähe eines infizierten
aufgehalten habe und die installation
wäre bei uns freiwillig anders als in
südkorea in südkorea geht die regierung
sehr massiv vor hier wird mit dem handy
nicht nur lautstark gewarnt sondern auch
handystandortdaten überwachungskameras
und auch kreditkarten daten genutzt und
teilweise gekoppelt um vor dem kontakt
mit infizierten personen zu warnen
cool kreditkartendaten kriege ich dann
als infiziert aber wenigstens payback
punkte übrigens in baden württemberg
haben gesundheitsämter jetzt einfach mal
klarnamen von infizierten an die polizei
weitergeleitet
also gut gemeint zum schutz der beamten
aber rechtlich naja ich bin mal gespannt
ob wir unsere deutsche corona tracking
er bald zum laufen kriegen
ich verspreche mir da echt viel von das
robert koch institut und die telekom
präsentieren das erste telefon dass man
immer und überall trocken kann unser car
am telefon wer damit telefoniert ist
garantiert bei sich zu hause
durch ein patentiertes system ist das
gerät mit einer sogenannten schnur an
der wand befestigt ihr vorteil sie
reicht nur bis zur haustür und
verhindert so dass man raus gelaufen und
jetzt neu für unterwegs das quarantäne
von togo mit allen namen der infizierten
im analogen kontakt speicher das karan
telefon
wir wissen wo du wohnst hightech made in
germany so zwei wochen kontaktsperre
liegen bereits hinter uns und für viele
kleinunternehmer und für viele
selbstständige tickt die uhr
einigen wird schon in wenigen tagen das
geld ausgehen da kann man nur hoffen
dass die staatshilfen rechtzeitig
ankommen
und natürlich ist es völlig legitim in
dieser situation über exit strategien zu
diskutieren
streit ist schon noch erlaubt sonst
kommen wir irgendwann so eine
merkwürdige wir kennen keine parteien
wir kennen nur noch viren stimmung es
stehen ganze branchen auf der kippe ich
kenne catering betriebe denen alle
aufträge weggebrochen sind catering
betriebe natürlich man will wirklich
keine dicken witze machen aber er zwingt
einen förmlich trotz der bedrohlichen
lage für peter altmaier
nahrungsmittelversorgung hatte die
politik diese woche eine glasklare
botschaft an uns bürger kontaktstelle
verlängert ostern fällt aus klappe zu
hause tot ich kann es nicht eine
wichtige botschaft des tages wir
verlängern die maßnahmen auch wir in
bayern müssen die maßnahmen wie die
meisten bundesländer verlängern
eine verlängerung der maßnahmen werden
die maßnahmen alle den bayern getroffen
sind verlängert werden also heute klare
botschaft verlängern ich bekommen
übrigens täglich briefe erst vor wenigen
minuten eine 10 jährige
hat mir einen brief geschrieben bitte
verlängern sie ja also wenn einer meiner
söhne demnächst anfängt briefe an markus
söder zu schreiben
schalte ich den schulpsychologen 1 die
maßnahmen werden verlängert und das muss
wohl so sein in dieser woche haben die
sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen ein
sondergutachten wegen corona
veröffentlicht und das kann man im
prinzip so zusammenfassen es sieht nicht
gut aus leider weil man sich aber heute
immer eine zweite meinung einholt
begrüßt hier an dieser stelle unseren
eigenen heute-show wirtschaftsweisen
olaf schubert wir haben extra für ihn
den sicherheitsabstand noch ein bisschen
vergrößert weise olaf was macht dir mut
dass die deutsche wirtschaft bald wieder
auf die beine kommt es gibt viele
signale die die hoffnung nähren
denn wir können uns jetzt der momentan
wirklich fragen was braucht unsere
wirtschaft wirklich braucht sie zum
beispiel so was wie miete ich glaube
nicht also ich kenne zum beispiel keinen
in meinem umfeld der gerne miete zahlt
also miete ist ja nur gut maximal für
vermieter und die sind ja nun wirklich
einer randgruppe
also ich finde miete können wir uns in
zukunft schenken und einfach ganz normal
mit applaus ab geltend nebenkosten das
gleiche mut macht mir aber auch dass
sich das home-office durchsetzt ich
meine das gab es schon immer aber ich
kenne jetzt einen fall ist ist
sicherlich ein extremfall aber ich kenne
ein der macht home office und der
arbeitet wirklich die welt ist aus den
fugen zu hause und das ist natürlich die
lösung im endeffekt auch für viele
andere berufsgruppen auch für mich so
ich meine warum soll ich meine wichtigen
ausführungen hier in so einem lernstudio
tätigen quatsch ich mache es in zukunft
zu hause in der küche da ist wesentlich
mehr los und für eine bessere stimmung
ja und so zieht sich durch branche und
branche home office für taxifahrer der
verkehr endlich rein ins büro türe zu
weg ist home office in der
landwirtschaft und da hast du dann so
ein klein sondern ein blumenkasten zu
hause macht der weizen reihenhaus den
ganzen tag glyphosat raus was weiß ich
mas zucht zu hause im büro klar gab es
früher auch schon hausschlachtung beim
fernsehen 3 kr würden die frauen mit der
kettensäge macht sie klein die kinder
lagen die knochen ab ja und was mir am
meisten mut macht ist natürlich dass die
gesellschaft mehr zusammenrücken die
menschen passen wir darauf sich auf
also meine frau die ihr hängt jetzt den
ganzen tag so gemütlich am fenster und
wenn sie eben sieht dass ein
spaziergänger den mindestabständen nicht
einhält dann gibt es keine abmahnung mit
dem luftgewehr stichwort exit strategie
welche geschäfte könnten deiner meinung
nach langsam wieder aufmachen mit der
zeit diese debatte halte ich für
verfrüht wir haben in deutschland große
probleme mit übergewicht jetzt durch die
ausgangs beschränkung hat das problem im
wahrsten sinne des wortes noch einmal
zugenommen
und bevor wir irgendwelche läden öffnen
würde ich erst mal die lebensmittelläden
schließen
und wenn ich mir dich anschauen oliver
für sehr lange zeit ja also ich meine
öffnen würde ich maximal so die soliden
kommst du zu sagen das schlimmste zu
verhüllen oder allgemeinen sage ich mal
so klamottenläden man sieht selbst
gelegentlich die menschen also das tief
wird wächst nicht mit seinen aufgaben
die baumwolle ist einfach überfordert
also als zugeständnis ist natürlich
würde ich bei märkte öffnen denn der ton
muss jetzt raus er muss jetzt
handwerkern der frühling ist da jetzt
müssen ja die stiefmütterchen
asphaltiert werden viele verlegen ihren
garten in die wohnung ja was weiß ich da
brauchen die gartenzwerge neue
betonfundamente ja das könnte man öffnet
abgeschlossen bleiben unbedingt müssen
friseure
denn wie die leute herum gerannt sind
früher mit mit diesen strähnchen
frisuren mit diesen asymmetrischen
scheitern mit diesen antrag ab mit
diesen gefährten haben das party und
jetzt setzten sich wieder die einfachen
frisuren durch die man so zu hause macht
eben hier moskau frühlings schnitt das
haus hält widernatürlich und das haar
kann wieder atmen das ist wichtig olaf
schubert vielen dank
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]